let's take a look now at apple shares of
the world's largest company by market
cap dropped to their lowest level since
reaching an all-time high in February
joining us now to discuss is our senior
markets correspondent Julie Hyman Julie
thanks so much the retreat yesterday
Apple went below the 200-day moving
average it did which is basically just a
technical indicator that people watch
sort of a momentum indicator I actually
have it on my Bloomberg terminal if we
can pull it up it's a yellow line that
that's how we map it on the terminal so
you can see it's the second straight day
we've gone below it the green sort of
bracketed line that we're showing is the
correction that we now see an apple
shares so they've fallen more than ten
percent that's technically typically a
correction i was looking back the last
couple of times we've seen Apple fall by
at least ten percent the last time was
the last time I went below the 200-day
moving average which was 471 days ago
because that's the period of time
between the two events and after that
went down a little more than ten percent
and then snapped back but back in 2012
we saw a more significant pullback in
apple of more than forty percent so it
went down considerably more at that
point before snapping back and going
higher we haven't hit the I mean I have
on my terminal right now the the chart
as well and it in pink I've got the
50-day moving average in green I've got
the 200-day moving average maybe we
could pull that up if we could you'll
see that we haven't reached the death
cross yet we haven't reached the point
where the pink to crop line crosses over
the Green Line what happens when the
death cry I don't the name implies
technical traders will tell you exactly
if you can't figure it out from the name
then you need to it's bad news those
skills but I wonder what our technical
traders or what are investors telling
you about the stock right now well there
seems to be some concern that's being
expressed here and in part because it
doesn't seem to be fundamental really
right at past times we've had apple
sell-off there's been more fundamental
concerns about product here yes there's
some concern about the Apple watch
there's still some concerns but these
are the same concerns about what's going
to be the next big thing for Apple it
seems as though at least for now the
watch is not it and there's also concern
because of apples importance overall in
the major averages now Howard
Silverblatt of Standard & Poor's Dow
Jones indices 70 some fun stats earlier
he's going back to that record that we
saw for the for Apple which was in
February it was februari 23rd and since
then the SP he said through today was
down about a half a percent I say
february2014 februari 23rd so that
graphic is wrong its 23rd anyway if you
exclude Apple the index is only down a
tenth of one percent so that shows you
the importance of Apple if you look at
the SP IT index down more than one and a
half percent since then if you take it
out it's actually up so really you're
talking about an enormous weight here
it's three-point-six percent of the SP
it's 4.4% of the Dow which is
price-weighted almost everybody holds
Apple in a portfolio somewhere so when
it's down there's a lot of page being
felt speaking of apples somewhere Tim
Cook eventually expects that china is
going to be the largest market but with
the equities over there taking a hit
look at what it's doing according to our
Bloomberg story Apple got 17 and a half
percent of its revenue from China the
last full year reporting period now
we're seeing that drop over in China
exactly that's a big one here it's
weighing on it to some extent although
the Apple Bulls and there will always be
a Bulls out there are sort of shrugging
off the China effect saying that's not
going to have that much of a depressive
effect on sales but I mean we'll see if
you're a regular person in China holding
stocks and now the value of your
holdings is worth a lot less is that
going to have an effect on your buying
decisions if you're trying to figure out
where they get the next phone